the juror experience kids in la
there's here being famous doesn't seem
like a viable option
in la it seemed like the most viable
option like the most
primary option oh you mean like there's
a there's a community of people that
are focused around the kardashians
and the the you know the athletes and
the musicians and the this and the that
and their whole ideas you know this
obviously sounds hypocritical it's
coming from someone who happens to be
famous but i think that
it's it's a empty pursuit it's you know
you can you can get famous doing a thing
that you love
or you can try to be famous and they're
two very different things
and i think there's been many times in
my life where i was trying to get famous
because it seemed like it was impossible
right like when i was young and first
getting on television first doing comedy
because it just seemed like impossible
like how does someone get famous how
does it i can see other people famous
like how are they famous
this is great it seemed nuts but be
careful what you wish for
you think uh you think fame changed you
like are we able to like
be cognizant of ways in which
the fact that this podcast is the
biggest podcast in the world and just
all of that how that's changing your
mind
i mean that i think about that with
power
that you might not be cognizant of the
way that power is changing you
that's why i find putin fascinating so
what um like do you look in the mirror
and see like you're not the man you used
to be
in some dimension like this is a
different human
because you're so [ __ ] famous
uh believe it or not
i think about that very little
[Laughter]
and i think this is my success i think
so i see that
legitimately i don't think i think just
interacting with you offline in general
i don't think you're
it doesn't look that you acknowledge to
yourself that you're famous
like you don't you're not living with
that truth
you're not like lingering it you're
still pursuing the things that make you
happy
that yeah i i
i tend to believe that you can do the
same with power like i
i tend to believe a president could do
that same kind of thing that's what we
would hope
right you would hope that some president
gets to a position of power not because
they crave it
but because they have solutions to
problems and they genuinely think that
they can help the world
i'm not saying that i'm not equating my
like i'm not um
uh favorably comparing myself to a
president or something like that but i
um i think i got a slow
drip of fame and that's one of the
things that helped me
you know i started i got on television
for the first time
in like the early 90s with doing
stand-up comedy
and then it led to a sitcom then led to
fear factor in the ufc and all these
different things
and then ultimately it accidentally led
to the biggest thing that i ever did
which was this was that is this the
biggest thing you ever did
this this this oh by far yeah by
by magnitudes
yeah massive giant numbers of magnitudes
different than anything i've ever done
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience